race Hustler Ibraham Kendy is under Fire
after his Center for anti-racist
research at Boston University laid off
some 20 employees more than half of the
center's Workforce the center for
anti-racist research was founded in June
2020 during the BLM Shakedown campaign
that followed the death of George Floyd
candy was given a professorship and a
center the purpose of which remains as
dubious today as it was back then
since that time Kennedy's Center has
raised tens of millions of dollars from
donors
and now
body knows where the money went
it isn't that the center produced
nothing for its money
the center launched a Blog on the Boston
globe's website
and then
that's pretty much it
the center promised to do lots of stuff
it promised to develop a racial data
tracker to be quote the nation's largest
online database of racial inequity in
the United States whatever that means
but that project like so many of its
other initiatives just never quite
happened
and it was never going to happen because
these race Hustlers never produce much
of anything their product is the
Shakedown
the product is white guilt
and the business is getting donations to
produce more white guilt to get more
donations
what did BLM ever produce
It produced lots of broken windows and
empty store shelves and burned out cars
and other than that all It produced was
white guilt which earned it some 90
million dollars in donations
which then also disappeared along with
the formal organization
the BLM Founders moved into mansions in
Southern California
and everyone moved on to the next grift
the only reason that we are hearing
about this one about the financial
Corruption of Kennedy's Center
is that he made the mistake of stiffing
his woke employees his fellow con
artists who are now turning the con on
him
but it almost certainly won't hurt him
because there's no shortage of white
guilt and there's no shortage of money
just waiting to be funneled into leftist
patronage
like a sidewalk shell game even if
Kennedy's bu gig goes under
just wait for him to pop up magically
somewhere else I'm Michael knowlesus the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show one in six
American adults can't name a single
branch of our government we will get to
why that might be in just a moment first
though speaking of liberal black men who
appeal exclusively to Yuppie whites
Trevor Noah just had an interview he
interviewed some well all right see you
later YouTube
[Music]
president Trump has hit the campaign
Trail
and he has identified a new nasty woman
you know he brought up that phrase first
against Hillary Clinton quite aptly now
he's turning that phrase on Megan Kelly
I sat down for an hour and then I did a
Megyn Kelly
one and she had you know just boy she
became nastier all of a sudden she was
pretty nasty didn't you think anybody
that watched it
I don't think she was particularly nasty
and more more to the point you know look
president Trump he's a good campaigner
he's a once in a generation political
Talent so far be it for me to criticize
his strategy that has worked
unexpectedly well for a long time now
but this seems to me a misstep
take aside any moral consideration take
aside that I'm friends with Megan Kelly
take a side that I think she conducted
the interview in a very fair way just as
a tactical matter
if if I'm Donald Trump if I'm on the
Trump campaign
I I think I've got to notice Megan Kelly
is not the enemy even though there was
that that spat back in the 2016 campaign
even though Megyn Kelly did ask him a
very tough question during the debate
said you've called women fat and ugly
and stupid and whatever and and Trump
had the unbelievably brilliant answer
which was only Rosie O'Donnell probably
the moment that he locked up that raise
just so fast on his feet so funny but in
this case
Megan Kelly has been very fair to Donald
Trump for many months now she's been
predicting for a long time that he's got
the presidential
nomination locked up I don't think she
connected conducted the interview in a
in a bad way and I just think there's a
principle in politics which is the
conservation of enemies you know you
don't want to grow your enemy list too
long and in this case I don't think
Megan is a fair enemy I made this
criticism of the DeSantis campaign when
I I felt that their online campaign was
just harassing and going after people
who were winnable who were potential
allies who at least were being fair and
were not were not the enemy
and I think that the same principle
holds true here maybe it doesn't matter
for Trump because he's just so far up in
the polls that he can afford to expand
his enemies list a little bit but
generally speaking I I think tactically
this is kind of a misstep he's on the
precipice of locking up the nomination
entirely the interview basically was
fine for him even though he kind of
whiffed it on a couple of questions I
don't think it really is going to upset
his standing in the polls seems Seems
needless to create an enemy where there
is not one
now we got to talk about these things
and when you want to talk to your
friends you got to check out pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com you know a
company is looking out for you when they
upgrade your service they don't even
charge you for it this is great news for
new and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with zero
price increase whatsoever if you've
considered pure talk before as you
should have but you haven't made the
switch yet shame on you take a look
again for just 20 bucks a month you will
get unlimited talk unlimited text and
now fifty percent more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot
this is one of the many reasons I love
Pure Talk they're veteran owned they
only hire the best customer service team
it's located right here in the great us
of a which is reason enough to switch
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that do not support
you when you go to puretalk.com Knowles
kwles you'll save an additional 55 zero
percent off your first month because
they actually value you go to
puretalk.com
wireless for Americans by Americans
speaking of gender
you've heard about this book genderqueer
which is this
perverse porn that liberal activists are
trying to push into schools even into
middle schools and elementary schools
and it shows graphic depictions of all
sorts of bizarre sexual acts and it's
just obviously inappropriate I think for
high schoolers too but in the context of
a school but certainly for middle
schoolers and Elementary schoolers and
this is the book that has been brought
up as the example by the Liberals of the
terrible right-wing book bands there are
those conservatives peddling their
censorship they're basically Nazis they
want to burn books we're not we're not
for burning or Banning books no siree
we're for free speech and free inquiry
and free expression but those left those
those right Wingers over there they're
the ones who want to ban books side with
us
and that has been somewhat persuasive to
liberals and even to moderates and
getable people in the middle we say oh
we don't want to ban books I was told my
whole life that banning books is bad so
I don't want to be on that side
but then
according to a new survey that's out
when you show voters what is actually in
genderqueer
all of a sudden they flip and 90 of them
say that the book is inappropriate more
than that 93 say that the images of
people doing weird sex stuff in
genderqueer is uh inappropriate this
according to the polling firm WPA
intelligence this is provided to the
Daily wire uh they say that these
sexually explicit cartoons are totally
inappropriate for public school
libraries and there's a lesson here for
conservatives
forgetting schools and genderqueer
whatever
when politics is abstract the Liberals
have the advantage when politics is
particular the conservatives have the
advantage
when we talk about the issue of
immigration
you say don't you think that people
should be led into the country don't you
think we should be open and inclusive
liberals win that immigration debate
when you say hey do you really think El
Paso should be run over by cartels who
are raping and killing and murdering
people conservatives win that debate
actually you saw this in real time in
2016.
for decades
as the debate over immigration had been
abstract liberals won that debate
When Donald Trump descended that
escalator and he said yeah Mexico it's
they're not sending immigration in
abstract they're sending murderers and
rapists and gangsters and human
traffickers and drug smugglers they're
sending really bad people who are
killing people in your towns in your
communities you see it with your own
eyes
then the conservatives started to win
that debate
while Banning books is bad yeah what
about this book you really think
seven-year-olds should be exposed to
extremely graphic images of extremely
perverted sex
oh no I don't think that
even even on the subject of Education
broadly
when when this kind of indoctrination
was just abstract you send your kids to
school and they learn whatever and they
come home and they're saying weird stuff
and they're doing weird stuff but you
don't know look at school it's a it's an
open education we're an open Society
parents did not become a powerful voting
block
what happened during covid though during
covet all of a sudden the classroom came
into the home and parents saw the
particulars of what their kids were
learning and all of a sudden parents
became the most fired up boating Block
in the country all of a sudden
Glen youngin wins a blue Commonwealth
the governorship in Virginia all of a
sudden Joe Biden's doj starts describing
parents in terms that they would usually
reserve for terrorists and domestic
violent extremists
the particulars are where we went and
this is good for us
because politics doesn't happen in the
abstract
that's a big mistake of our modern
liberal age politics happens with real
people in real places in real time it's
not just an idea it's not just
principles floating in outer space it's
real people in real time so
any Republican campaign any activist
campaign
if you want to win and you're a
conservative you got to get down into
the particulars the particulars are far
more Tethered to reality speaking of
particulars in campaigns
a new poll out from CNN and University
of New Hampshire
Trump is at 39 up in New Hampshire
Ron DeSantis is now down to fifth place
very very bad news for the DeSantis
campaign because the DeSantis campaign
has pulled back some of some of its
staff from Super Tuesday
and the later primary States and
accidentally they seem to have pulled
out of Nevada which is actually an early
primary state but whatever uh
DeSantis needs to do well in Iowa that
won't be sufficient though because Iowa
hasn't predicted the eventual Republican
nominee in over 20 years and DeSantis
needs to do well in New Hampshire and
DeSantis needs to do well
in a number of the early States and the
numbers are going in the wrong direction
so Trump's at 39 percent
now uh Vivek is at 13 Nikki Haley is at
12 Chris Christie is at 11
so underneath Chris Christie you get Ron
DeSantis
you dig into the numbers on DeSantis and
the picture looks even Bleaker because
the biggest drop has been among
moderates moderates were backing
DeSantis 26 percent back in July
they're now backing him six percent now
so he's had this huge colossal collapse
among the moderates his drop among
conservatives has been smaller
which could be predicted is drop among
conservatives has only been eight
percent but moderates is where he's
collapsed
you know I hate to say I told you so
this is not his fault
this is what
I said was going to happen
and the reason I saw this happening is
because
Ron desantis's Lane in the race his only
Lane in this race is to be the
anti-trump candidate which is to say the
the more moderate alternative to Trump
even if you think Trump is actually
secretly a rhino or he's a Democrat or
he's he's really not a rock ribbed
conservative okay that's not how he's
viewed he's viewed as the the right
flank of the party
and I I think somewhat fairly on issues
like trade on issues like immigration I
think he's he has hearkened back to a
sturdier older more right-wing
conservative tradition but even if you
don't think that that's just how he's
perceived
the the people who want an alternative
to Trump who clutch their pearls and
gnash their teeth they tend to be the
more moderate side of the party they
tend to be the Lincoln project they tend
to be the people who watch MSNBC and CNN
so that's where DeSantis has to be to
have even a shot in the race but but
DeSantis isn't that guy DeSantis is at
his very best when he's to the right of
Donald Trump DeSantis is at his very
best when he's more pro-life at least in
his rhetoric than Donald Trump is
DeSantis is at his very best when he's
more opposed to the sexual Revolution at
least in his rhetoric than Donald Trump
is DeSantis is it his very best when
he's more in favor of wielding state
power for conservative ends than Donald
Trump is
so that's that's where he's strongest
that's that's what makes him an
attractive candidate to many of us
but he doesn't have that lane in the
race
is Lane's got to be the moderate Lane
and so he's got to pick one and as he
moves more toward the moderate side he's
going to lose the conservatives who are
going to probably stick with Trump and
as he moves more toward the conservative
side he's going to lose the moderates
has happened in New Hampshire if the
DeSantis campaign continues on the path
that it seems to be on there are going
to be all sorts of postmortems about how
he's just a very flawed candidate and
he's uh he just wasn't up for it or how
the campaign was poorly run and I don't
think the campaign's been run
particularly well but I think all of
that is just missing the point
which is it doesn't need to be that he's
a terrible candidate it doesn't need to
be as some people I think are
preposterously saying that DeSantis is a
chill leftist Rhino liberal or whatever
it doesn't have to be any of that it
doesn't even have to be that his
campaign was poorly run
it's just that the circumstances of the
race in this bizarre year where you've
got the first former president running
for a non-consecutive second term since
with all of the questions about the
state of our democracy and election
integrity and the upending of the covid
lockdowns it just
the circumstances have a say to and the
circumstances don't seem to be favoring
a challenger to Trump
now what are we going to do about that
well we're probably going to go home
and we're gonna we're gonna work on
ourselves work on our bodies enjoy the
pleasures that we've got one of those
Pleasures is
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles we've
all got very busy schedules science
fairs the kids dance recital prepping
for Christmas well the good news is you
can take one big thing off your plate by
putting great meat on your plate with
good ranchers you care about what your
family eats so does good ranchers
they've spent years building
relationships with local farms to Source
the best 100 American beef chicken pork
and now wild caught Seafood to the best
of the land and the Sea the proof is
just in the product it's the best
product out there it the prices are
absolutely unbelievable they're now
giving you two years of free ground beef
to anyone that subscribes that's a 480
value they lock in your price which is
completely insane I absolutely love it I
eat good ranchers as much as I possibly
can is one of the sad things about me
going out on the road is that I don't
have that sweet sweet little Elisa
cooked good ranchers when I get home for
dinner they're just phenomenal act fast
because this deal will not last forever
good goodranchors.com today use code
knowleskin wlas 25 bucks off free ground
beef for two years subscribe to any box
to lock in your price on America's very
best meat for two whole years as well
goodranchors.com today use code Knolls
for over 500 bucks in savings subscribe
to good ranchers American Meat delivered
my favorite comment yesterday is from
the drummer's workshop at Norm's music
who says at a government-controlled
grocery store in Chicago you can trust
that the prices as well as the customers
will be slashed
really really great point so true
speaking of polls one in six Americans
cannot name
single branch of the US government
according to the Annenberg Constitution
Day Civic survey
which is released every year
long-standing survey
a large number of Americans can't name
three branches of government
two-thirds of Americans
can name the three branches so one-third
of Americans cannot name all three
branches of government
ten percent of Americans
can only list two branches of government
and another seven percent can only name
one branch of government
and then what's really crazy is that a
full 17 percent of Americans
cannot name a single branch of
government
why is that is it because people are
just really dumb now
I don't think IQs have necessarily
dropped
I don't think I don't think that
explains it I don't think that you know
a father has an IQ of 100 and then his
son has an IQ of 90 and then his son has
an IQ of 80. I don't think that's what's
going on exactly
I don't think it's just that the
education system has collapsed so that's
part of it I think and I know this is
going to be politically incorrect
it might have something to do with the
all-time record high waves of mass
migration that we've seen for the last
60 plus years that immigration into the
United States legal and illegal over the
last 60 I guess closer to 70 years now
has been the largest movement of human
beings ever in recorded history and this
is no knock on the immigrants I'm not
saying the immigrants are all big
dummies or that they don't even like
America or I'm not saying any of that
just saying that when you flood a
country with foreign people they're
going to be less conscious of the
particulars and the peculiarities of the
country into which they're moving
because they just they weren't raised in
it they don't have that even if they
studied for a Civics test you know the
test to allow them to become citizens
which for the illegal immigrants doesn't
doesn't even matter
they're not going to have that kind of
instinctive down in your bones
understanding of the country they're not
going to have that generational
knowledge and that matters I know that
the left-wing liberals and the
right-wing individualists don't want to
say that that matters but it does
generational stuff matters the only
reason that anybody talks about the
pilgrims on the Mayflower these days is
because there are still a fair number of
people who descend from them and who
have just a family interest in them
if if those people didn't exist no one
would talk about it the only reason
people talk about it is because they
have genealogical interests in them the
same goes for the Sons and Daughters of
the American Revolution the same goes
for all sorts of Civic associations that
have a genealogical component to it
very Politically Incorrect to say these
days but John Jay said it John Jay a
very important Founding Father first
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court one
of the authors of the Federalist he said
with equal pleasure I have has often
taken notice the Providence has been
pleased to give us this one connected
country to one United people a people
descended from the same ancestors
speaking the same language professing
the same religion attached to the same
principles of government very similar in
their manners and customs and who by
their joint council's arms and efforts
fighting side-by-side threat a long and
bloody war have nobly established
General Liberty and Independence it's a
hard Truth for an age that is opposed to
very basic conservative truths that if
your family has been in a place for a
long time you're going to have a little
bit more of an attachment to it than if
you've just arrived on those Shores just
a fact
I'll give an example I was just in
Hungary
I really like Hungary I love what the
government is doing in Hungary I think
it's a beautiful place I love the
Thousand-Year history of Hungary as a
Christian Nation part of a broader
Empires fought valiantly they've got
great food they've got they got great
stuff
if I moved to Hungary though to tomorrow
I would care about Hungary a lot less
than your average Hungarian on the
street whose ancestors go back a
thousand years it's just a fact maybe if
I stayed in Hungary for a very long time
maybe many generations down the line my
descendants would have a similar care
for Hungary and Hungarian culture and
history and the quirks of how the
society Works maybe but it would take a
long time
politics doesn't just happen overnight
we have a strong focus on democracy and
and the the present and the uh we ignore
a lot of history well
for a democracy to really work for it to
remain stable and not be as the founding
fathers feared the worst form of
government you you need to take into
account a deeper democracy which is that
democracy that I think it was Edmund
Burke talked about I was confused this
quote between Burke and Chesterton but
it's the Democracy of the Dead
it's probably Chesterton the way it's
written so so cleverly and with such
Whimsy that we shouldn't just prioritize
the the members of our democracy who
happen to be walking around the earth at
any given time we should also give some
care back in the generations and also
forward and care about our nation's
future but we don't do that anymore so
what do we do we tear down statues of
our forebearers and we leave as an
inheritance to Future Generations
nothing but a pile of debt
not conducive
to a stable country if we lose that
stability and we lose that sense that
there's something
if not sacred at least worth admiring
and even venerating about our past then
we're just going to lose the whole
country it's just going to fall apart
and you're seeing this happen now
speaking of erasing History New York
City is looking to remove the statues of
our forebears according to a list found
in New York City's Council uh agenda
this is for Tuesday September 19th
officials will consider a bill that
would quote require the public design
commission to publish a plan to remove
works of art on city property
that depict a person who owned enslaved
persons or directly benefited
economically from slavery or who
participated in systemic crimes against
indigenous peoples or other crimes
against humanity
what does that mean you know the way
that this is going to be interpreted
especially by the race Hustlers at
things like Ibrahim Kennedy's Center for
anti-racial blah blah blah
this means everybody this means
everybody in American history
because all Americans have in some way
been could at least be said to have in
some way benefited from slavery because
slavery was a part of the American
economy for a reasonably long time
and a lot of our forebearers not not all
or even most of them but a lot of them
own slaves
and it was just part of the economy so
if you interact with it in any way
you're taking part in it think about
this today for a thousand years in
Western history usury was basically
illegal
lending money at interest was more or
less illegal and that's because
Christianity considers usury to be a
crime and a sin
I continue to believe that I continue to
hold two Christian teachings and yet
today it is impossible
virtually I think just flat out
impossible to in any way participate in
society without somehow participating in
usury
it's just it's just part of the economy
so if
500 years from now we get rid of usury
somehow and our descendants say you know
we're going to tear down the statues of
anyone who participated in that awful
sin and crime of usury they're going to
tear down all of the statues because
it's just part of the error that we
breathe it's part of our society so
these attacks as as Donald Trump
predicted these attacks on Robert E Lee
these attacks on Stonewall Jackson these
attacks on those mean old nasty
Confederates to tear down their statues
it was never going to stop with them it
couldn't stop with them it was always
going to move on to George Washington
and Christopher Columbus and everyone
all of them every at crimes against the
indigenous what does that mean that
means any white man who ever came to the
Western Hemisphere could be accused of
such a thing because the indigenous
people were here before us
well all of them the pilgrims Plymouth
Rock
the whole thing has got to go
and what are we going to be left with
we're going to be left with a big
nothing country
where far fewer than one in six
Americans can name anything about our
Civic life now I've told you time and
time again I don't want to say
that I didn't warn you the yes or no
game has sold out over at
thedailywire.com shop
it will come back in stock but you need
to secure your game right now if you
still haven't we are ordering more we're
ordering as fast as we can but they sell
out it sells that every single time
so if you want the game for your
Halloween party if you want the game for
your Thanksgiving get together with your
family if you want the game even for
Christmas order it now so that you're
not caught in the Lurch when it sells
out again also if you've already got the
classic game be sure to get the new
conspiracy theory expansion pack in time
for spooky season speaking of my
collection and the change of season
if you're familiar with this show you're
probably aware of my autumnal affinity
for a certain seasonal treat I'm talking
of course about the PSL the pumpkin
spice latte what better way to bring
fall into your home than with the
all-new oh it's a little cinnamon it's a
little vanilla it's a little pumpkin
spice obviously pumpkin spice Michael
Knowles candle
wonderful smells fill up your whole home
with that autumnal
Delight now available in my collection
do not wait order your candles and your
yes or no game right now dailyright.com
shop
finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com Knowles to save an
additional 55 zero percent off your
first month
take it away
hey Michael I was recently rejected by a
woman that I truly felt that God had
placed on my heart
I've never really felt that way about
anyone in my life I've been in plenty of
relationships I'm 30 years old I've
recently experienced an unprecedented
season of consistent spiritual growth in
a fantastic Church community and after
asking God for wisdom I really felt that
I was in tune with whom God intended for
me rather than some random girl that I
wanted to pursue according to my own
plans it saddens me knowing that she
continues to sit completely alone at
church every week and she despite being
my age and very attractive is still
single and doesn't seem plugged into a
group of friends how should I think
about this does God not speak to
Christians about their lives if
scripture does not directly address a
particular issue in our life
are we on our own and if my feelings are
indeed in tune with God's wisdom and not
my own should I continue to entertain
the possibility of her changing her mind
or forget about it and move on thanks
Mike well you're never on your own
God's always there with you you should
turn away from God but you're never
you're never actually on your own uh but
there's a big if there you say well if
my desire for this girl
and my belief that we're gonna end up
together is actually in align with God's
wisdom and not just my own desire or
fantasy then you know what's going on
here
but that's a big if
you just don't know you say the girl
doesn't doesn't seem to have any friends
you don't know that all you see this
girl is is at church on Sunday or maybe
she goes to daily mass you see her every
day but it's still only for an hour
so you just don't know that
you might be projecting that onto this
girl you don't seem to know this girl
very well
now it could be the case that this girl
is just a bit shy or a bit odd or you
know and so maybe if you
become friends with her a little bit or
you chat a little bit more maybe you can
convince her to go on a date with you
but maybe not maybe she just doesn't
like you
you know not to be too harsh about it
man but
you she gets a say too
and so you might have this sense you
might have a desire for this girl and
you might have the sincere sense that
God has ordained this girl for you
but maybe not
maybe that isn't the case and maybe you
gotta look elsewhere
uh
there is a distinction between love and
infatuation and if you really don't know
this girl if you've barely ever talked
to this girl you just see her across the
church and you think she looks cute then
you know your deep feelings of love for
this girl are probably more akin to
infatuation than an actual love I don't
mean to discourage you I mean you know
being of a certain Italian extraction
uh
I think it's it's good to pursue girls
even if you know the girl says I don't
want to have a drink I don't want to go
get a cup of coffee the first time maybe
maybe ask one or two more times you just
try to you know say no but listen you're
very cute and I'd like to take you out
to get a drink or something so come on
ah come on how about that uh so maybe
that will work for you but
you also have to accept the reality that
yeah you you just might not be her type
even if you think she is your type so
what I would recommend is even as you
perhaps leave open the possibility that
this girl might like you uh go out with
some other girls
it's okay you can explore you're a
single man you you want to get married
I'm not saying go be debaucherous or
anything like that but you can go on
other dates there is also a strange fact
of
human nature which is that
if you are going out on dates and it's
clear that
women like you and are attracted to you
more women will like you and be
attracted to you
you shouldn't use this in a way that's
exploitative or any anything like that
but
Drew claven once gave me advice which is
I said what should I do in my career and
he said well the more you work the more
you work now so the more you're just
doing anything the more you're gonna
be likely to do the things that you want
to do and I think that's probably true
in personal life too
if this is true if you want to make more
friends go out and do things with people
just really anything and you're more
likely to
make more friends that way and it's true
of women as well next question
hey Michael I know we've talked about
this before but regardless of what I
think what is your unbiased opinion on
high school graduates not going with the
traditional route of college and going
with something more alternative like a
gap year ywam or trade school
also being a parent does that affect
your view of college at all especially
with how well gets becoming from your
pen with the green pants
my friend I know I know who this it
might be someone even in this building
who's asking me that question
um
it gets back to the point I made earlier
in the show it's all about the
particulars I know there are some
conservatives who come out they say
don't ever go to college don't go to
college college is stupid
I think some people should go to college
well if you go to college just you
should only major in engineering I don't
think that's true in fact I think very
few people should I don't think that's
the point of it a university education
studying engineering is good becoming an
engineer is good but I just don't no I
wouldn't say that some people should
study Dusty old books
well okay then everyone should go to
college no I don't think that either I
think way too many people go to college
when I went to college something like 70
percent of high school graduates
went to college right away that's insane
and that number has dropped
precipitously but it's largely dependent
on what you want to do
so if you're extremely academic and you
want to go study
Plutarch or something I don't know you
want to go study you Virgil then yeah
you're probably going to do that in a
university environment if you're not
particularly academic and you want to do
other things then why would you waste
your time in college if you want to get
married and start a family a little more
quickly you could do that too if you
want to take a gap year and maybe
you know go on some missionary trip or
go on some internship or or if you want
to just start working right away you
could do that too I think I we just need
more information and I think I know who
wrote in with that question
um
so I I guess in that particular I would
say
if you're not that inclined to do it
don't do it I don't want to sound trite
or cliche when I say follow your bliss
but you know don't try to slam a square
peg in a round hole if it's not for you
then then allow your desire to
help guide you towards something that is
more conducive to your flourishing not
saying just do whatever you want
whenever you want to do it but if you're
more drawn to some kind of
I don't know missionary trip or if
you're more drawn to some kind of
internship or if you're more drawn to
family life and settling down right away
I don't think that's necessarily a bad
thing I would I would judge that desire
uh in the light of virtue and reason and
come to a conclusion that's right for
you and in many cases that's going to
mean no College though in some it might
mean go to college next one
hello Michael Alex here again
long time listener huge fan currently
about to finish my conversion
Catholicism thank you to you being a big
part of that and leading me to that end
just the truth of the one true church so
thank you so much anyway here's my
question so a discussion I get it
frequently with one of my uh Protestant
friends is the Immaculate Conception
I've I I someone understand it and I'm
trying to listen to many people like Dr
Tony Marshall explain it who's much more
intelligent I am but I would just love
to hear your elevator pitch or your kind
of dumbed down version if you will for
somebody like myself of how to how do I
not only how do I explain this and fully
understand the Immaculate Conception of
Mary how is it that even though the
Bible says that all of sin and fall
short of Glory of God how do I explain
this a Protestant that Mary was sinless
said she she really was Hail Mary full
of grace and sinless so thank you so
much Michael Kaling for your answer God
bless well you just partially explained
it right there
which is the Full of Grace part but for
those who don't know the Immaculate
Conception refers to the conception of
Mary without the stain of original sin
so a lot of people think it refers to
the Virgin birth you know or the
conception of our Lord Jesus Christ
without a human male participating but
it refers to the conception of Mary and
so this raises a problem in the minds of
some people which is well hold on I I
was told that all sin and fall short of
the glory of God so that's got to
include Mary too right because that
that's literally what it says
but if we were to interpret that verse
in the most strict literalism we
possibly could then we would have to
conclude that our Lord Jesus Christ
sinned and fall fell short of the glory
of God because he is among the set of
all
he's a person
right so did Jesus sin no of course not
that's absurd
all sin and fall short of the glory of
God is a true statement about Mankind
and human nature but
our Lord Jesus Christ is obviously an
exception to that rule and the Blessed
Virgin is an exception to that rule too
does this mean that Mary didn't need a
savior no certainly not the Immaculate
Conception is a Catholic dogma but it's
a it's been a belief of Christians since
time immemorial which is that Mary was
preserved from the stain of original sin
by a singular and special Grace of Jesus
Christ so it is it is
still that Jesus Christ sacrifice on the
cross is what redeems mankind but that
there's a special ordering of that in
the case of Mary one way to describe it
would be if you fell into a ditch and
then I come along and I pull you out of
the ditch I saved you from the ditch
right but if you were walking toward a
ditch and I said hey hey
step around that there's a ditch there I
also would have saved you from the ditch
but I would have saved you from the
ditch before you fell into the ditch
which is what our Lord did to his mother
uh part of the reason for this is that
as Christ is the new Adam Mary is the
new EVE uh and both created without
original sin uh part of this is because
Eve is the new
Ark of the Covenant Covenant Christ is
the New Covenant and Mary is the new ark
of the covenant and the Ark of the
Covenant is immaculate stainless but we
also see this in scripture too which is
when uh well as you say hail Mary Hail
Mary full of grace the Lord is with thee
this phrase full of grace is not hey
you're partially with race it's that
you're full of grace and then you see
this in the greeting from Elizabeth to
Mary which is she says blessed are you
among women and blessed is the fruit of
your womb Jesus so this same word
juxtaposed right next to one another to
refer to the blessedness of Mary and the
blessedness of our Lords it is a
singular type of blessedness and then
you just have 2000 years of the
Christian tradition so if you say well
that doesn't really convince me Michael
I'm not persuaded uh you know that's
you're just reading parts of scripture
or you're just uh deducing certain
things by reason
um but you know that's not really what I
believe where is it in scripture more
directly or something I guess I would
just have to ask why is it that
Christians have believed this for two
thousand years and then in more recent
centuries people stop believing this
that's why I just would always ask the
question of History why one's views
which are supposedly so ancient or out
of line with history and then I would
ask the question of authority
uh when people say well I just read my
Bible and I know what it means you say
well a lot of people read the Bible and
they have all sorts of varying
interpretations so so you haven't
sidestepped the question of authority
who has the authority
of interpretation in the interpretive
principle and even if you don't
believe in the pope yet or something you
know even if you don't believe in the
the authority of the church you might at
least believe in the authority of the
vast majority of Christians who have
lived going back to the apostolic age
okay I've got one more voicemail back
question to get to I've got
the mail I've got the written mailbag to
get to and it is of course fake headline
Friday so I need your help and please
I'm just going to say I'm going to read
the headlines and then some people are
going to say oh it's number three is
number four the chat is slow but they're
going to say that one don't you got to
tell me which headline you're going to
use the words from the headline the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member use code null
scanner WLS to check out for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
um